some of us belong to a social group
politely known as warriors that is we
are close to panic on a range of issues
pretty much all the time we worry that
the scratch on our knee will turn
cancerous that will catch a deadly
disease from touching the hotel door
that all our savings might disappear in
a random economic disaster and that our
enemies could spread rumors that will
forever
disgrace and demean us so overwhelming
and debilitating can these fears become
we may be advised by well-meaning
friends that we should probably go and
visit a psychotherapist in haste in
order to calm ourselves here we're
likely to learn a lot of very reassuring
things in particular that none of our
powerful fears is really any kind of
reflection on what's likely to happen in
the real world the scratch on the knee
is just a scratch
there isn't about to be some global
catastrophe there isn't some disease
that's going to wipe us all out the
hotel door is blameless we're not going
to be financially ruined
no one is properly interested in
humiliating us and so on and so forth we
learn to make a distinction between our
inner world and the outer world the
first filled with terror and
apprehension the second emerging as a
far more benign indifferent and
easygoing place we also learn if we read
a little psychotherapeutic theory why
there should in some of us be such a
dislocation between the inner and outer
worlds it comes down to a theory about
childhood some of us had childhoods that
were so disturbed and cruel so filled
with shame and loneliness that they have
colored our view of the whole of life we
assume that things will always be as bad
as they once were the task of
psychotherapy is then to start to show
us how powerfully and negatively biased
our perceptions are and that the adult
realm actually contains far fewer demons
than we thought
and far more opportunity solace and
forgiveness we learn that the
catastrophe we feared would happen has
in fact safely already happened we get a
lot better but then if we're unlucky at
key moments in our lives we may run into
a range of harrowing events that
threaten to upend everything we
carefully learn to believe in and that
make a mockery of the soothing voices
we've come to trust suddenly in spite of
our best efforts to be resilient and
sane we learn that we are in fact facing
a mortal illness or after slowly
overcoming a compulsive hand-washing
fetish we're told that a germ truly
might kill us after all Oh
despite our attempts to explore our
sexuality with courage we learn that
some enemies really do want to humiliate
us for the pleasures we've pursued in
confusion and bitterness we may turn
against therapy and its naive view of
reality and cry bitterly see it really
is as bad as I always thought it was I
suspected that life was hell and it
really is Oh
as one comic is reputed to have had
inscribed on their gravestone I told you
this wasn't just a cough this may sound
like the moment when all attempts at
psychotherapeutic calm or an emotional
maturity and wisdom more broadly should
fairly come to an end but once we've
endured the initial panic we can
actually insist that this need be
nothing of the sort we can strive for
wisdom despite or even in the midst of a
range of the most awful external
eventualities we should be clear on
what's at stake psychotherapy does not
promise us that nothing will ever go
wrong in our lives again it can't remove
intractable evils
what it can do however is to teach us a
variety of mental maneuvers that will
render those evils death among them a
great deal less painful and persecutory
than they would otherwise have been
there are better and worse ways to enjoy
the afflictions we cannot avoid
there are ways of interpreting disasters
that add a whole new layer of pain and
fear to them and others that while they
don't magic away the chaos at least
remove its secondary aggravating
characteristics let's consider two of
the things that those of us with a
choppy inner life and probably a
difficult past may quite unfairly tell
ourselves when we run into the
difficulties of life and compare it with
what wiser voices might propose firstly
this is going to be the end of
everything it doesn't take very much
when you've already felt a disaster or
to rock your world at an early age to
know in your bones what's coming next
when a problem hits death is clearly
nigh there isn't going to be any safe
way out of this debacle it's all over
but however counterintuitive this might
sound even in a pandemic one may be
exaggerating even with a cancer
diagnosis one may be losing perspective
the outer world can be bad very bad
and still the inner world can be making
it worse may be adding yet more fear yet
more dread and more of a sense of doom
than would be strictly necessary not
every calamity is the end and not every
end need to be a deluge some of us will
have enjoyed the blessing of that
essential figure of early childhood the
soothing adult a toy broke and it seemed
it was a misery beyond compare
we wailed we screamed we call death upon
ourselves nothing so bad had ever been
seen but then a kindly adult came took
us in their arms and said I know I know
and held us so tightly until our tears
abated and then in a calm and loving
voice they plotted with us how we might
repair things perhaps there'd be a
similar toy in another shop maybe we
could get some glue and have a go at
fixing the head back on maybe there'd be
a way of playing with it even if it had
only one leg and so gradually we
recovered a taste for life and kept on
going and many decades later when
disaster strikes once more we're able to
call on that voice of the kindly
parental figure and give ourselves more
options certainly it is bad but think of
how much remains
perhaps we can pick up the pieces and
begin anew maybe the horror will end
there might just be a small solution and
even if there isn't the kindly voice
gives us a sense that everything can be
okay anyway even dying can be coped with
for maybe the original owner of that
calm voice approached their end a few
years back with serenity and good humor
and we can now emulate that in turn not
even death has to be a disaster
you deserve all the bad things that
happen to you
for some of us it isn't just that bad
things happen to us bad things happen to
us because we are bad people we suffer
because we deserve to suffer and we
deserve to suffer because we are to put
it relatively mildly pieces of [ __ ] it
feels natural to turn whatever is
negative and might have been entirely
accidental into a verdict on us and on
our right to be we have such reservoirs
of shame and self-loathing that when we
suffer a reversal we don't only end up
for example sick or broke or abandoned
in love we hear a voice in our heads
that at once adds immeasurably to the
misery a voice that tells us that we are
aside from on our own and in a cold
rented room also a mistake that should
never have been born no one doubts that
sometimes people go broke no one doubts
that love lives can go wrong but not
everyone who goes broke or has a bad
marriage ends up feeling that they are
the worst person in the world and that
the leading option must be to kill
themselves for some of us we aren't just
our worst moments we can exist outside
of our foolishness no error we make ever
puts us entirely beyond the pale we may
be in prison most of our friends may
have left us but we still know we've got
lovable sides someone could in theory
still see past our sins and love us we
tend to believe that the difference
between a good and a bad life must lie
strictly in the quality of the events
that befall people but to a surprising
extent the difference actually lies in
the way each of us is able to interpret
events there are newly convicted
prisoners newly condemned patients and
freshly diagnosed plague victims who
know how not to add shame persecution
self-hatred and unbounded panic to their
already considerable burdens there are
those of us who know how to incorporate
a soothing commentary to a battlefield
who can tell ourselves in the middle of
an inferno that we do not deserve this
that a lot can be fixed that we are
still lovable
there is an old misanthropic joke that
goes just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean someone's not following you
the true retort to this grim wisecrack
would be and even if someone is
following you
that doesn't mean you deserve it or that
it has to be the end of you and in a
related move just because there is a
plague doesn't mean you're gonna die and
just because you're going to die
doesn't mean you can't ever grow to
accept your non-existence with a measure
of dark humor and serenity even at the
end of the world there will be some of
us taking it worse than others some of
us who will feel that they deserve it
that this means they're disgusting and
wretched and that none of the beautiful
staff ever meant anything and there will
be others who will be greeting
catastrophe without catastrophizing the
good news is that long before the planet
expires with a little help from therapy
and philosophy we have the capacity to
move ourselves into the wiser camp the
camp of those who can endure difficult
things without adding a further critical
persecutory commentary those of us who
are able in the face of the most awful
events to soothe themselves with the
kindness and empathy of the gentlest
parent calming down the sobs of the
distressed and frightened child we all
once were and at some level all remain
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more